a court in Pakistan has granted former
prime minister Imran Khan two weeks bail
he's facing multiple charges including
corruption on Thursday the Supreme Court
ruled his arrest earlier in the week was
unlawful Kamal haidar has more from
Islamabad
Imran Khan was told by the Supreme Court
yesterday after they ordered his release
I think that he should go and get a
contact the Islamabad high court for
relief in this particular case that was
brought against him by the national
accountability Bureau and now the court
of course granting him two-week bail
Imran Khan also said that he was
apprehensive that there were plans to
arrest him from outside there were other
cases in which he had to get bail the
court granting him bail in other cases
also and issuing an order that he cannot
be arrested in any new case till the
17th and that's why Imran Khan now will
be leaving the court premises to go back
to his home in Lahore